this is Jocko podcast number 101 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing
good evening echo good evening second
lieutenant Bernard Wilford long was a
smart young man who went to Birmingham
University at age of 16 back in 1912 he
was commissioned in the West Yorkshire
Regiment in January of 1916 and Bernard
or burn as his family called him served
in World War one in France and he wrote
this letter to his father in early
August of 1916 he said we've been having
it awfully wet here during the last day
or two and my word talk about mud it's
simply awful
I get into mud up to my knees I can take
a sporting risk as well as any of them
and shells have got no fear for me I've
seen great big burly chaps who do
nothing but curse and drink and get down
and pray like a child when there is a
bombardment on and they don't care who
sees them and no one dares to joke about
it I've just heard from a pal of mine
from Brockton who went down to the some
when I came here and he says he's been
over the lid seven times and attacks on
the boast line pretty awful that isn't
it and I marvel he's alive to tell the
tale he wrote another letter to his
mother on August 11th 1917 I am off by
an early train tomorrow for the rest
billets behind the firing line where we
shall be for a time to get to know our
men etc I am going up with two pals and
we are all pleased I shall think of you
all while I'm up there and know you
won't forget me
we're fighting hard now and is a serious
game
we're all ready to lay down everything
if need be and if God wills I'm ready so
goodbye and wish me luck your loving son
burn and second lieutenant Bernard
Wilford long was killed in action at age
21 at the Battle of langemark on August
16th 1917 four hundred men from his
battalion went into action all ten of
the officers are from the battalion died
along with 264 of the men on September
11th 1918 there's another young man
Sergeant David Kerr an American who
dropped out of Columbia University to
fight in World War one he sent a letter
to his mother the day before the attack
on st. Miele in France and he wrote
tomorrow
the first totally American drive
commences and it gives me inexpressible
joy and pride to know that I shall be
present to do my share
should I go under therefore I want you
to know that I went without any terror
of death and that my chief worry is the
grief my death will bring to those so
dear to me since having found myself and
Mary there has been much to make life
sweet and glorious but death while
distasteful is in no way terrible I feel
wonderfully strong to do my share well
and for my sake you must try to drown
your sorrow in the pride and
satisfaction the knowledge that I die
well and so clean a cause as his arse
should bring you remember how proud I
have always been of your superb pluck
keep Elizabeth's future in mind and
don't permit my death to bow your head
my personal belongings will all be sent
to you your good taste will tell you
which to send to Mary may God bless and
keep you dear heart and be kind to
little Elizabeth and those others I
loved so well
David the end and while the Americans
actually broke through the German lines
in the attack they suffered 7,000
casualties in 72 hours of fighting and
20-year 20 year old David Kerr was among
the dead and that attitude that attitude
where death is not feared we can find
examples of it in so many different
places a great example is from the
American Civil War
from a man by the name of Sullivan
Ballou now after the battle at Fort
Sumter in 1861 President Lincoln called
on the states to form up militia troops
to put down the rebellion and Sullivan
Ballou who was born in Rhode Island was
one of those volunteers and he was
commissioned a major in the second Rhode
Island Infantry Regiment it was third in
command and the second Rhode Island
infantry regimen moved to washing
and joined the union army of
northeastern Virginia and on the 14th of
July 1861 from Washington Sullivan wrote
his wife a letter then here are some
excerpts from that letter
my very dear Sarah the indications are
very strong that we shall move in a few
days perhaps tomorrow lest I should not
be able to write you again I feel
impelled to write lines that may fall
under your eye when I shall be no more
our movement may be one of a few days
duration and full of pleasure and it may
be one of severe conflict and death to
me not my will but thine o God be done
if it is necessary that I should fall on
the battlefield for my country I am
ready
I have no misgivings about or lack of
confidence in the cause in which I am
engaged and my courage does not halt or
falter I know how strongly American
civilization now leans upon the triumph
of the government and how great a debt
we owe to those who went before us
through the blood and suffering of the
revolution and I am willing perfectly
willing to lay down all my Joy's in this
life to help maintain this government
and to pay that debt but my dear wife
when I know that with my own Joy's I lay
down nearly all of yours
and replaced them in this life with
cares and sorrows when after having
eaten for long years the bitter fruit of
orphanage myself I must offer it as
their only sustenance to my dear little
children is it weak or dishonorable
while the banner of my purpose floats
calmly and proudly in the breeze that my
unbound
love for you my darling wife and
children should struggle and fierce
though useless can contest with my love
of country I cannot describe to you my
feelings on this calm summer night when
two thousand men are sleeping around me
many of them enjoying their last perhaps
before that of death
and I suspicious that death is creeping
behind me with his fatal dart and
communing with God my country in you
Sara my love for you is deathless it
seems to bind me to you with mighty
cables that nothing but the omnipotence
could break and yet my love of country
comes over me like a strong wind and
bears me irresistibly on with these
chains to the battlefield the memories
of blissful moments I've spent with you
come creeping over me and I've feel most
gratified to God and to you that I have
enjoyed them so long and hard it is for
me to give them up and burn to ashes the
hopes of future years when God willing
we might still have lived and loved
together and seeing our sons grow up
honorable to manhood around us I have I
know but few small claims upon divine
providence but something whispers to me
perhaps it is wafted perhaps it is the
wafted prayer of my little Edgar that I
shall return to my loved ones unharmed
if I do not my dear Sara never forget
how much I love you and when my last
breath escapes me on the battlefield it
will whisper your name
forgive my many faults and the many
pains I have caused you how faultless
and foolish I have oftentimes been how
gladly would I wash out with my tears
every little spot upon your happiness
and struggle with all the misfortune of
this world to shield you and my children
from harm but I cannot I must watch you
from the spirit land and hover near you
while you buff at the storms with your
precious little Freight and wait with
sad patience till we meet to part no
more but Oh Sarah if the dead can come
back to this earth and flit unseen
around those they love I shall always be
near you in the garish day and in the
darkest night amidst your happiest
scenes and gloomiest hours always always
and if there be a soft breeze upon your
cheek
it shall be my breath or if cool air
fans your throbbing temple it shall be
my spirit passing by Sarah do not mourn
me dead think I am gone and wait for
thee for we shall meet again as for my
little boys they will grow as I have
done and never know a Father's love and
care little Willie is too young to
remember me long and my blue-eyed Edgar
will keep my frolics with him amongst
the dimmest memories of his childhood
Sarah I have unlimited confidence in
your maternal care and your development
of their characters I call God's
blessing upon them Oh Sarah I wait for
you there come to me
and lead thither my children Sullivan
and on July 21st 1861 the regiment took
part in the First Battle of Bull Run and
as one of the senior officers Sullivan
went in front on horseback to direct his
men and he was hit by a cannonball that
tore off his right leg and also killed
his horse and he died from his wound a
week after the battle while a prisoner
of the Confederate Army at age 32 again
an individual obviously prepared to make
the ultimate sacrifice and we know that
the enemy can be equally prepared to die
and we saw that clearly from the
kamikaze pilots from Japan in World War
two one of those young kamikaze pilots
was named you keel are Iraqi and he was
a member of the 72nd Shin boo squadron
and he wrote this letter dear father and
mother I trust you and my brothers are
doing well recently it has been decided
that I will go at last to take part in
the Battle of Okinawa as a member of the
Special Attack forces I am deeply moved
I only look forward to sinking a ship
with a single blow when I look back I
apologize for not being devoted to you
in any way for some 10 years to this day
through teaching by various senior off
SURS after I entered the army I now
devote myself to my country as a special
attack force member please find pleasure
in your desire for my loyalty to the
Emperor and devotion to parents I have
no regrets I just go forward on my path
I ask that you teach my three brothers
so they can serve our country as noble
Airmen I sincerely hope but you take
good care of yourselves and make
strenuous efforts on the homefront
please give my regards to all my
relatives and to everyone in the
neighbourhood Association sayonara you
keel rocky then he did indeed die at the
age of 17 in a suicide attack on
American ships near Okinawa on May 27th
1945 and the Japanese also imposed their
willingness to die on their people and
here is a description of that brutal
imposition from American sailors from
the Journal of an American sailor named
James Farr he who served on the USS
Montana and this is what he wrote on
November 10th 1943 this afternoon we
came across a raft with four live Japs
in it as the destroyer Spence came close
to the raft
the Japs opened up with machine gun at
the destroyer the Jap officer then put
the gun in each man's mouth and fired
blowing out the back of each man's skull
one of the Japs did not want to die for
the Emperor and put up a struggle
the others held him down the officer was
the last to die he also blew his brains
out the Spence went in to investigate
all the bodies had disappeared into the
water there was nothing left but blood
at an empty raft swarms of sharks
everywhere
the Sharks ate well today we went to
battle stations
and at 10 p.m. we were attacked by enemy
planes later darkness descended and the
rains came and just coming off the
episode that we did with Musashi who
obviously overcame his fear of death and
I got a book in the mail from Japan and
the book was called the hundred rules of
war that's from someone in Japan named
Erik Erik Shahan who turned out to be
the actual translator of this book and
he's translated a bunch of other
Japanese books on martial arts and he
asked me if this book the hundred rules
of war if any of the the rules inside
this book applied to modern warfare and
I read through the book and I read the
book and it came to a very clear answer
that yes not only do many of the rules
in the book apply to modern warfare they
also apply to life in general like many
of the rules that I talked about and
this book the hundred rules of war which
by the way only has 97 rules in it but
the book was originally written by suka
hara bokuden who lived from 1489 to 1571
so that's actually before Musashi's
lifetime because Musashi was born they
say in 1584 so this this book predates
Musashi and there's there's actually
multiple revisions on this book it's
interesting people would get it and add
something to it over the years there was
a foreword written to the book in the
mid 1600s by taka Wan Soho and then
there was an afterword written by one of
the grandchildren of bokuden students
and there's another section the first
eight lines in the book that were added
and those are attributed to shogun Yoshi
moon and he's a shogun that ruled the
japan from 17 16 until 1745 so this book
is very interesting and since Eric who
sent it to me is obviously fluent
Japanese I'll apologize of course for my
bad Japanese pronunciation but we'll go
for it and now I'll want to take you
through some of the sections of this
book that again I feel not only applied
to combat today but to life today and
interestingly here's the we'll start off
a little bit with the introduction and
this is again written by what written
after the original book came out and
this guy added this introduction to it
and he's describing how great the book
is a little bit of arrogance in this but
it's okay cuz he's saying hey he's not
saying he wrote it he's saying look this
book is important
and here we go to the book if you change
out the people if you change out the
words if you change out the places and
if you change out every generation it is
like the difference between rain Dew
snow and ice they are each formed by the
same water that's interesting
right because now we're talking about
people they you can be different times
different places different different
surroundings but it's like the
difference between rain and Dew and snow
nice it's the same water and the same
people are the same
back to the book these words should be
read by any and everyone who follows the
way of the warrior speak them aloud so
that you may hear them in your ears and
fail to heed them at your peril
they're not simply words to revere and
praise if you are attempting to equate
the teachings within this scroll to any
other work know that this is knowledge
that can be found only after summoning
the tallest peak of a mountain the depth
of the wisdom contained on these pages
makes the sea seem shallow by comparison
if you were to compare a person versed
in these ideas to a stone you would find
the latter soft by comparison pull a
bowstring launching an era or pulling a
bowstring launching an arrow raising
your whip encouraging your steed donning
your armor taking up your Lance gaining
Fame and honor and becoming one who
starts a great house read this book
listen to it understand the unmistakable
truths it would be utterly foolish to
not lock them in your mind in my opinion
even if you lived through a hundred
generations over a thousand years coming
across another book like this would be
like to a blind turtle who comes to the
surface once every hundred years
climbing its way into a hole on a piece
of driftwood I like that now as we jump
into this book there's one more thing I
need
I said that there's these editions kind
of to the book over time well one of the
additions to the book I mean this book
was written in the fifteen hundreds but
one of the additions to the book and
this is something that that Eric added
that he found a translation of the book
by a researcher and a practitioner of
the sword arts and this guy's name was
hoary so he and he produced the text and
he put little helpful interpretations
kind of furthering the idea a little bit
so I'll read those sometimes because it
gives a little bit of clarification as
to what's being talked about and these
first eight lines are actually I'll give
it up for these first eight lines in
this book being a fairly epic fairly
epic and again these were written by
Tokugawa Shogun Ieyasu Muni and again he
was the Shogun ruler of Japan from 1716
to 1745 and here's what he added to the
book and I think these are well here's
number one you cannot have pleasure
without pain and you cannot have pain
without pleasure your struggles now will
be rewarded in the future so you must
endure right yes kind of speaks for
itself
does it not in fact I think we call that
discipline equals freedom next be
reverent towards the law be afraid of
fire be afraid of thoughtless delusional
people and never forget to be reverent
to those you owe a debt of gratitude to
this is one of those things that what do
we say now never forget where you came
from right people say never will forget
where you came from
well don't forget those people that got
you there yeah cuz where you came from
somebody helped you along the way
mm-hmm and so don't forget about that
next one you should think of greed and
lust as the enemy
I concur I think I like this one
you should neither sleep late nor talk
too long now I guess I'm kind of the
talk too long I may be violating that on
a regular basis at least once a week on
a podcast yes me too sometimes actually
you might violate that on a regular day
actually but here's here's a guy don't
sleep late and you know I get this all
the everytime I every time somebody
talks to me about sleeping someone says
why I have the night shift yeah or well
I work late and my kids don't go to bed
until midnight okay I get it
I'm not saying everyone in the world has
to wake up at 4:30 yeah what I'm saying
is this you shouldn't sleep late right
yeah if you work the night shift not
sleeping late might be waking up at noon
yeah yeah you didn't oversleep is my
point
yeah it's the idea just like I say like
we all want to like stay cozy in our bed
and kind of take our time right kid I've
been kind of thing yeah it's the idea
for sure that's what I get from you
anyway it's not the mandatory yeah
4:30 and if you don't wake up at 4:30
years Blacker's yeah like someone
someone I picture my hands on the
interweb right mm-hm and I look Alice
get removed sure on the pull-up bar and
on the pulley yeah yeah yeah bless
someone someone someone said hey if
someone doesn't have calluses they don't
work out and then someone else said well
what if you run a marathon you still
work out yeah and you know if it's the
20s get some right kids can you get some
wall training for a marathon yes yes you
get someone run your marathon
yes you can you know look at look at Rob
Jones you know he just ran 31 Mary one
days yeah that's getting some we're not
accusing him of not working yeah yeah
all right next take care to organize
even trivial things then if something
major occurs it will not catch you
off-guard hmm so that's the little
things that matter the attention
you know military when you join the
military I joke about it they make you
fold your underwear mmm in like a four
by four inch square mmm and that's the
thing they're trying to teach you
attention to detail yeah cuz actually I
was talking to marine buddy of mine I
think it was I want to say it was Morgan
yeah in they were they landed their helo
and the gunner or whoever was in charge
of the weapon cracked off a 50 Cal round
into the whoa so you have a 50 Cal
mounted in the in the helicopter guy
cracked off around he if a weapon gets
hot it can just shoot okay yeah yeah the
weather's really hot it's called a
cook-off you've got a browned in the
chamber and the weapons hot and it can
just make that round to go off from what
the what anything just whether they're
from hop if it's hot well you're
shooting it okay the side then you add
you shoot it up on stand now it gets hot
there's a hot round sitting in the
chamber yeah and a minute goes by or you
don't know him you know how long it's
gonna be it could be a minute could be
five minutes but boom all of a sudden
just fires yeah and this so before in
this particular case I'm not sure the
weapons system it was a 50 caliber but
I'm not sure where they had it mounted
but anyways he should have cleared it
before he folded it up into the
helicopter mm-hm and he didn't do that
and so he pulled the the rounds out but
there's one round sitting in the chamber
and sure enough it cooked off that's the
kind of thing where they're trying to
get you to pay attention to the small
details yeah the trivial things
yeah the trivial things aren't too
trivial yeah d-did they except do they
explain that to you like one when you're
folding your underwear do they explain
okay then you know at all they they do
and I've talked about this before on the
podcast that my drill instructor in in
Officer Candidate School at the end of
officer Candice Cole he explained why on
everything at the end at the end all I
guess to me of you of course know while
you're doing it though they'll they'll
be saying how can you you can't even
fold your underwear not right how can we
trust you with a weapon system yeah
they'll say that kind of thing to you
but you don't really when you're well
when I was going through regular boot
camp well you're just trans mind is
being trans
formed from civilian world to military
world so you're not you don't have a
good perspective yeah you know you're
like weapon system man disciplining the
next meal yeah you're not you can't see
the big picture I mean I couldn't I was
too young or too dumb or a little bit of
both yeah but they do they're saying hey
how could you how could you how could
you trust how could you
via airplane mm-hmm if you can't even
fold your underwear right boy youth
you're actually thinking well damn maybe
I shouldn't be flying it's late I
fucking underwear right yeah but they're
trying to teach you attention to detail
and it is good and it does apply to
everything you know it does apply to
everything and you you do the little
things right and that way the little
things are in order
and that means the big things even if
they catch you a little off-guard you're
at least prepared for it yeah yeah that
that whole thing that I mean I dig it
you know how they're talking guys like
that but that whole thing where how do
you expect to do this when you can't
even you know tie your shoes right or
whatever you know like say you don't
bind to that I do know it's good you're
like how are you gonna run cuz a lot of
things it's like a false little
equivalent see there some some things
they're telling you to pay attention a
little yeah no I got attention a DJ I
get that part of it for sure but I'm
saying like if they're not explaining
why I don't and it could be wrong well
they're explaining why but they're doing
it they're not doing they're not
breaking it down right you know like a
schoolteacher is right okay well this is
Echo Charles let me tell you what
they're not they're saying hey we trust
you the rifle if you can't hold your
underwear right yeah okay and I would
say this maybe I didn't see the big
picture but I he saw the little picture
well yeah well that's we know everything
ultimately like um you know like and I
mentioned mr. me like uncredited right
where he's like wax on wax off you know
and he's like oh so dumb then at the end
he gets the picture you know but as he's
doing it I mean he didn't say you know
if you can't send the floor how are you
gonna fight in the tournament nothing
like that but well he was teaching of
some kind of technique allegedly right
but that's essentially what they're
doing as far as attention to detail
there makes you in do all these little
jujitsu that would make you there's
nothing
I'm sure there's no sit there foot walk
pieces of wood yeah but that's pretty it
like that's an obvious translation you
know like sure I'm gonna feel awesome
it's like punching a punching bag you
know same thing do just to very check
alright
going to the next one ninety percent is
not enough only 100 percent will keep
disaster at bay that's good now of
course many times I'll say hey eighty
you got an eighty percent solution to go
right cuz people sit around and wait for
the right hand good blend which so I
think that's a little bit different but
this I think if you're talking about
effort yeah right the effort has to be
hundred percent yeah I'm not gonna give
a hundred percent and it's a settling
thing too right weird you know people
don't like settle you know don't settle
for ninety percent when Brett it's 100
percent is required exactly effort or
what yeah that's what I get from it next
having good judgment also means being
able to endure in your take pain and
it's not just pain it's also being able
to take just just I like no yes yeah
like discomfort and like how many people
don't want to do a job just because it's
it just cuz it's grueling and not fun
yeah right yeah
not right now currently obviously but
you know in general yeah that's my
general attitude from for the most part
sometimes what was the worst most menial
job that you really ate it my worst job
that I really hated was being a mover at
American movers on Oahu in Hawaii for
the summer but then you get a little bit
what like like a man I'm gonna move this
thing really fast no other people all
day like he knew his bed is like 13
hours a day average that work construct
I ever tell you about when I work
construction and the first day on the
job site they the guys came into the
Wendy's I worked at Wendy's sure and the
guys look to me in the in this old
Italian guy builder he looks at me goes
what are you doing here oh good I said
I'm making rent he says you want to work
here I said no sir he said you want to
work construction with me I said yes sir
mmm he said report tomorrow we're over
Crockett they were build the place right
across the street yeah
I said yes sir so I showed up there in
the morning and there's there a dump
truck had come with a ton of concrete
block to that we're gonna build a little
foundation wall and they just dumped it
you know a hundred yards away all these
concrete blocks you know and he says hey
your job today is to move these blocks
over to get him over here near the
foundation thing he said we're going to
get some coffee and some doughnuts sir
yeah doughnuts so I said yes sir mm-hm
and he got in the truck with the guys
right and I started moving these blocks
I was running I was running yeah
literally running as fast as I could
possibly do it and I wasn't even doing
that as like a challenge to myself I was
so happy to not be working at Wendy's
yeah that I would have I mean I just was
filled with energy so I get all these
blocks done and another guy was there
who didn't go to get coffee no nuts and
he kind of gave me hey man you need to
slow down yeah you know you're gonna
make everyone look bad yeah and I would
just say hey I'm going pretty slow huh
I'll do whatever you know I'll do your
job you can sit there me don't care you
know but what do you do any of that you
didn't get any I mean you didn't propose
little challenges to yourself yeah a
little work crew that's actually how I
got by it was like okay let me do this
if there's a way to get by you should
tell people because some people are
stuck in jobs that they don't like right
at this moment in time they're listening
to podcasts and they're working at
Wendy's yeah and I worked at Wendy's bro
they get that locker down are their
worked at full up but dude what
this guy in the back stock pee shoes and
stuff like that yeah you know it's funny
man uncle I working at footlocker was
kind of when you'd walk in it like
that's kind of cool you get to wear the
ref uniform and all that and that's good
man when we we're in high school yeah
man we start working I was like this is
it's tedious it's weird how your
perspective changes yeah I was thinking
about that the other day when you're a
young team guy and you get like when I
got my first apartment mmm dude I was I
might as well man Dom I was the richest
guy in the world you know yeah it was
like I was the man yeah but then as you
you know you settle into that then you
say well you know what I need to be cool
I have a little house I'm not you got to
be weary of the greed that's true that's
true but that's natural though right
it's like you know when you get used to
something it becomes the new standard
you know how that whole thing works
right well okay then what's the
difference between someone because you
and I both know P we all know people
there's people that get to the comfort
zone and then they're done what's the
difference you know that someone that
gets the comfort zone and done and
someone that gets the comfort zone and
says all right I'm comfortable here but
I want more yeah I want to do more maybe
not want more because that implies a
materialistic point but I just want more
huh yeah because they're both like
really like obviously prevalent and like
almost natural can get both of those
personalities exact but that I'm sure
we're all like but we're both of that
I'm sure everybody is both of those
things in one way or another you know
like in oh yeah you know like we're
probably both in like the comfort zone
big time as far as certain things you
know I don't know what a hotel but you
know I can't know either what's really
interesting because if you think about
it you see someone that's got seventy
percent body fat yeah and you go dude
yeah that dudes got 70 percent body fat
that's got like that sucks like yeah
that person should work you know try and
get that trying to drop that percentage
down yeah but there's someone that's
looking at me some guy that's obsessed
with being lean as hell he's looking
mean like god I can't believe Jacko's
got whatever yeah 20 percent or 18
whatever my percent body fat is yeah
he's looking at me going do
well you know pain so why my comfort
zone no no no no no I am no no because
it's not like you were getting after
looking after your body percent levels
and then you hit a certain number and
then you were like eh who cares kind of
thing I don't think that that's a good
way it went here's what have and not
with you obviously I can't speak you
know as far as your comfort zones go but
a typical one will say is that you know
guys will be working out and like
getting their fresh haircut or whatever
and then they'll get married and then
they won't work out as much guys girls
whatever you know and do that they quote
unquote let themselves go after they get
married like that kind stuff but they
might focus a lot more on their career
and then they might want more of that
but then then you know it's like that
kind of stuff yeah I think you know
watch out for the comfort zone yeah
alright next oh now we've moved beyond
those opening lines and now we get into
the bulk of the book which again which
is written by this book again guy and
here we go it does not matter whether
you are filing firing at an enemy near
you or an opponent some distance away
you should be a depth that's selecting
the best Arrowhead and then the the
amplification on that says the lesson
here is that you need a strong arrow for
an adversary at close range but a
lighter one for hitting an opponent far
away and I guess when I read this the
point that I got out of it was you you
need to be able to select your tools
properly right this man and as a leader
you need to be able to select think of
all the tools we've talked about on this
podcast that you need to use as a leader
some guy just got to be a little bit
harsher with a guy sometimes you got a
big you're gonna flank a guy sometimes
you got to be directors all these
different tools that you need to use as
a leader you gonna be a depth at
selecting the right tools and I gave a
metaphor on here one time about about
how you're like a woodworker right this
is actually what's interesting about the
word work or metaphor is as a leader you
have to be like a woodworker which means
you need to learn all these different
types of tools but
you need to learn how to use these
different tools on different types of
wood and each one of these types of wood
each one of these individual pieces of
wood is a little bit different they got
a little knot they get a grain they get
things so you you can't just learn a
mechanical skill yeah you have to learn
to be a true craftsman with the tools
and then you have to learn about what
the different types of people they are
and then you have to see that each even
a different type like this person might
have a big ego but they got this other
thing you all not they get a little
different grain yeah like a barber you
know using the Clippers well yeah and
you he busts out the thing and it
depends you know yeah that's true like a
barber or I guess we could say any type
of craftsman that has to work with
varying medium sure yeah pretty much
anybody really everybody you've watched
the social network right watch that show
it sounds weird it's a when you first
hear the ideas of Facebook you Bob about
Facebook and uh Coburg the first when
you hear about that you're like okay but
bro that's a good movie really good
movie anyway it's a movie I thought it
was a show or a movie a movie okay the
social network is he awkward yeah yeah
it should it's really they overdo his
awkwardness you they maybe maybe yeah
maybe I don't know I don't really follow
Zuckerberg to know his awkwardness or
whatever but I ever heard people call
him sucks yeah it sucks like that but he
he's he's he's doing something he's he's
breaking into the college commuter or
mainframe whatever he's breaking into
and he's kind of narrating what he's
doing he's like I had to do this so I
had to break out this this you know and
he's doing the same thing that was a
really revealing part in he's got a yeah
so he's trying to solve these prey it's
all code and you know so he's trying to
solve this problem but then this problem
comes up and then this one has these
specific problems so he has to solve
them but he can't just deal with the
current tools he has to bust out the
vision when he was creating it of what
it was gonna be
well did he feel that confident about
Missy did he see the whole vision or do
you like wake up one day and say dang
this thing's gonna be really no no it
was it was it like it was a slow
evolution into it
at first it was like he started with
this thing called face smash which was
basically just comparing the girls on
campus like who's hotter hmm and then
you click okay she thought her and then
he go to the next one
she thought anything you know Dan that's
cold-blooded yes and that was the big
part of it was like that's what people
would hate him stuff like that and then
it just slowly no I was a social network
these guys never like what a teenager
would do right oh yeah big time and
that's what they were trying to
emphasize - more like he just wanted to
be liked liked by people or he made that
um I thought that was gonna help him be
like this is just what the Moose I don't
know you know I'm sure there's some
inconsistencies with it but nowhere does
it would be weird to meet him well not
just to meet him like hey nice to meet
you but to actually know him I guess
because then you see what someone's
there's been there's been people and
I've kind of known that were whatever so
to semi-famous or so or whatever the
word is sure
and and in real like on TV they seem
like they're not cool people but in
regular life they're really cool and
then the opposite I've also seen where
someone is seems super cool yeah when
you see their persona and then in real
life
they're not cool yeah yeah I guess
they'd be pretty common to kind of be
inconsistent that way or or have it be
inconsistent as far as your experience
with that person seems like they'd be
kind of common right because a lot of
people if they're famous or if they're
you know famous poppy or whatever you a
lot of times you kind of got to turn it
on for the camera all right
especially because you're essentially a
performer in one way or another whether
it be actor or whoever you know even
like businessmen you know like it's
weird and it's not even necessarily a
bad thing it's more like for lack of
better term a required thing you know so
like my brother for example like if I
know him but then when I hear him
talking to like like I don't know
executives or something or like every
once a while he'll I'll see him on like
an interview or something and I'm like
like he there's only because I know I
know so good look like I just thought of
Joe Rogan yeah so I actually met Joe
Rogan a long time ago when I was just
Dean's one of Dean's cornermen right you
know you know how Joe Rogan treated me
back then Oh super cool that's cool
just the same I've been when I was up on
his podcast they say yeah same dude that
that yeah that's a good dude right there
I mean agree and strangely enough I had
the exact same experience and this is
and this will this will kind of
demonstrate how legitimate it is right
so same exact story I'm at Doral again
for the first time with Dean and my wife
we went to we kind of knew red band
through it it's a long story so we went
to one of his shows we got to go to one
of the shows and go talk to him
afterwards right so that's the first day
I met him same thing super nice game
easy mail yeah yeah and then so the next
time I see him was when I went to
Legends to Train when I was gonna LA for
you know the filming and so I trained at
Legends and so I go there and he's there
he's rolling with everyone and
everything you know it's like he's known
there whatever you know like become just
another person there this for his
training us and then um so he's kind of
cruising down the side so I'm gonna go
ask them to roll I was like hey well
Toby I met you with Dean long time ago
you know a few years ago whatever he was
like he was like yeah that must have
been a lot like he totally did it
remember me you know it's not like I
remember you so now I'm gonna be cool to
you it was like he did totally did I
remember I mean I was probably one of
many people and he was still just as
cool so he starts talking about UFC you
know how like you know hey small talk
before you guys roll and then um so it's
small talking starts talking about
current UFC stuff we didn't even roll
you I just want to listen to him talk
about UFC and so he they're all but same
thing same exact thing and then and even
when I went up to film with him for the
meta more stuff for Eddie Bravo stuff
same thing he like forgot about me again
that was like years ago and he was like
oh yeah that must've been a long time
ago same exact like yeah actually I
actually respect the fact that difficult
oh yeah yeah remember yeah yeah fully
yeah he's he's doesn't play that game ya
know I actually met 80 million people
last year I don't really remember you
but it's good to hang out with you right
now again yeah exactly I guess exactly
in
this I mean of course yeah joe rogan is
like this and it if people are like this
in general that is just like I said
that's kind of like a litmus test but
kind of like it's this indicator you
know he didn't remember me so really
since he didn't remember me for all
intents purposes I was just another
person and same exact treatment just
cool just normal
oh yeah it wasn't like I mean you're you
and there's this separation kind of
thing it was none of that
ya know it's a good way to be yeah I
don't know how he ended up talking about
that one
you dropped your drug in the name and we
start talking about it so you know good
point name job
alright next your mouth should be of
normal strength and spirit horses with a
strong urge to win or fearful and
skittish should be rejected out of hand
so I thought this was interesting
because we're talking about finding
someone that's balanced right mm-hmm no
not someone that's he's a normal normal
strength in spirit don't want someone
that Spragg grow right but you don't
want someone that's weak you want
someone that's in the middle and the
amplification on it says horses without
nerve are weak while a horse with a lot
of spirit cannot be ridden by normal
people hmm in other words a slightly
strong somewhat plucky horse is best
plucky by the way second time we've
heard that word today this is a sign
don't learn to work do you know what it
means I didn't know it no no he's brave
plucky mean lorry means brave okay does
indeed how to look that one up similar
here as long as a horse is strong is
acceptable it is acceptable for it to
have a certain inclination however never
ride a horse with a tendency to retreat
so if you got a strong horse it's
basically to me this is as long as the
thing is not gonna turn tail if it's a
little bit feisty if it's a little bit
this a little to that you can have a
little bit different person and what I
took away from this is as a leader
once again you're gonna get people with
some things going on it's a little
personality trait some little
when you're putting together a seal
platoon you're gonna have some guys that
are got some idiosyncrasies right yeah
you got a you got sixteen guys in a seal
platoon you've got 36 guys and it's
asking it that they're not all the same
by any stretch and some of them are
gonna be even further outside the box of
Naruto they're gonna sure they're gonna
have some kind of this idiosyncrasy we
might even call it an issue like that's
kind of an overused word but I'm still
got an issue right sure okay what this
is saying is as long as they're not
gonna retreat and run we're all right
yeah but if they're gonna retreat and
run if that's their idiosyncrasy get up
yeah get rid of them
what do you call deal break the deal
breaker deal breaker deal breaker big
time all right next while small horses
may be easier to handle as well as
dismount from those who prefer such
animals are a bit dim-witted so what I
like about this is if you're in a
leadership position you might want to
surround yourself with people that are
just weak they'll just do what you say
and they're saying yeah yeah I want my
horses all just to fall in line and it
easy to get on and off and if I yell at
them they don't they don't bark back
yeah you don't want those people you
want people that are a little bit harder
to handle just a little bit harder to
handle maybe they're gonna stand up to
you like I always say you don't wanna be
surrounded by yes men you want to be
surrounded by people that will question
you'd say I don't like this plant so
that's the kind of horses you want not
not little tiny weak horses no next
you should know that a person wearing a
newly forged sword will invariably
blunder even if that sword cuts well so
basically this is like you got to watch
a new guys a little bit wait wait they
don't again it's it's you should know
that a person wearing a newly forged
sword will invariably blunder even if
that sword cuts well okay so you gotta
watching you guys and here's the
amplification on this one a sword that
is not at least a hundred years old is
one that you cannot rely on God okay
yeah like young people full of vigor and
energy the vitality of a young sword is
not entirely stable you cannot rely on
it
hey you got a watch yeah you got a watch
unproven unproven mmm gotta watch him
that makes sense to me
I'm not saying there won't be bad asses
yeah might be right they might be I had
new guys that were complete badasses but
you don't know that I also had new guys
where you think they're gonna be good
it's weird man but talking about buds a
little bit lately
sure some of my friends you you have no
idea who's gonna make it through yeah
you don't know cuz it's mental right
you're you can he is their best a mental
and physical its mental and physical hey
can you get cut from buds just because
you're not like let's see is there like
I don't I don't know but you know like
let's say there's a run mm-hmm and you
got a you know do you do they or is
there any circumstances that are this or
similar to this where you gonna make
this run in you know 10 minutes whatever
and if you don't make the 10 minutes
you're out yeah but there's the flavor
sure absolutely
there's a there's actually the standard
time so the runs have been in place
since I went through and they're the
same mmm
for the for what they call a four mile
timed run yeah the four mile timed run
in first phase the time maximum time you
can take is 32 minutes 32 minutes
would you run in that's that stuff
you're surprised cuz that's slow right
four mile that's a timer that's an
eight-minute mile that's pretty fast
what it's pretty no it's pretty fast
then in second phase it goes down to 30
minutes bro you used to run a what oh
yeah I could do it but it's not like
that yeah let me tell you that is not
fast that is not in second phase it goes
to 30 minutes in fourth phase it goes to
28 minutes that's a seven-minute mile
that is not fast yeah I thought you're
gonna say like 10-minute mile this is
what this is what trips people up or
jams people up as you like to say what
jams people up is when you do the run
you're not fresh that's the thing you're
not you're wearing boots boot pants
you're on the soft sand on the sand yeah
yeah and okay the sand like part of it
will be hard pack yeah but then like
part of its gonna be soft and and this
has changed a little bit from what I've
been told when I went through the
instructors maybe that run was 4.2 miles
is 4.5 miles maybe it was they was three
point eight miles they kind of estimated
so if you didn't make it the time so
we're not when I went through if you
didn't make the time for that four run
mmm they had your name if you failed
again you were done okay so it's like
one strike yes okay gotcha now the
interesting thing is if you fail to run
mm-hmm and then you fail to swim mm-hmm
do you could still we would still be
there if you fail the runners running
again yeah if you fail to run and to
swim and you failed on the obstacle
course you'd still be there don't one
more time they call it being on the
bubble yeah actually that actually came
from officer candidate school I don't
think we said the bubble there's new
things that that that develop and buds
yeah take that come yeah I've heard on
the bubble plenty times you're on the
bubble buds that just means in general
like oh yeah you get cut yeah so thanks
okay so that that's what you mean by its
physical cuz like yeah it's physical
like if you don't yeah you can fail I've
been telling people this lately I had to
run
fast as I could possibly run the pastor
runs for that forma I would that would
be me too
and the one time one time I paced myself
it's like you know what I'm just gonna
pace myself I'm sure I'll be fine I face
myself yeah I felt like so then from
then on and I had a buddy that was a
cross-country runner in high school or
college or something mm-hmm and he's a
hey run with me and I'm like yeah I'm
dad and I didn't hate Brant as hard as
it and that's how I had to run every run
I had to run as hard as I could
yeah and there's guys that ran
cross-country those drones are a joke
for those guys I mean yeah eko it's no
big deal for I mean there's a lot of
people that can run 5-minute miles yeah
that are doing those runs and you know a
four mile run in like 22 22 minutes yeah
and I'm not saying that's not true I'm
surprised that you thought that was fast
I think I just caught you off guard it's
slow dude it might be slow do you mean
the way you mean my fast and depends on
me my slow when I used to like run out
run on the treadmill and I would run a
seven minute allow it to be like at
Redmond black Devils are no that's part
of my point you run on the treadmill I'd
run like a seven-minute mile pace and
I'd be like dang and but I'd only do
like one mile and it'd be like good
that's I've I've only run on a treadmill
like it's easier it's yeah you're like
in fact I was on board ships I would run
around the flight deck yeah so that's
what I mean these guys running seven
eight minute MA
usually when I'd run like four miles or
five miles on the treadmill it'd be like
ten like just under it like a nine
minutes something like I don't even know
how to translate to a treadmill I
honestly don't
oh I don't know how that translates yeah
so I would say it's like but a 9-minute
mile is pathetic right that's and that's
what the pace outrun my four miles and I
want to be dead but I'd be that Beach
that's there's a hardware so I mean if I
if you want me to run an eight-minute
seven-minute eight-minute mile with
boots in sand even some of the time
you're crazy
I would be no distance runners what I'm
hearing apparently yeah I would be going
like you as fast as I possibly can to
make it check back to the book
while you should select a sword with a
handle that is long and thin
you should reject any sword with one
that is excessively long I like that a
lot of these rules are balanced they're
about balanced that's what they're about
hey you want it long and thin but don't
that's too long
yeah you want a horse that's strong but
not overly strong yeah this is a lot
about balance and here's the
amplification you are less likely to
drop a sword with a thin handle however
in cold weather you are liable to drop a
sword with a thick handle for the most
part went on horseback you should pass a
string through the handguard of your
sword and tie it to your arm once you
drop it you be able to pick it up again
have lanyard hmm have a lanyard on your
weapon the leash have a board no that's
different fishes are for dogs I had my
whole career had a landed on my pistol
hmm only needed at one time dang I don't
think I've even heard of eating meat I
only dropped my pistol one time huh yeah
yeah next again balance it is good for
the tip of your spear to be long however
if it is too long you may find yourself
in trouble amplification the blade on
the end of your spear should be long but
not excessively so if it is too heavy
then you'll lose it balanced got to keep
things balanced next even if you were
able to fly up into the sky without
feathers you have no chance of victory
with a spear you cannot wield with your
own tailor two hands I like that one
mm-hmm is that kind of like girls over
packing for a trip and making you carry
their stuff I don't think it has
anything to do with that kind of but
when you really think about it think
about it oh cuz she can't carry her it
is all her stuff that she needs and
she's gonna do well on the vacation as
far as comfort goes whatever but she can
in theory well you you got a K if you
would
made it not about vacation but about
patron Lee hung them through the woods
right like it's great that you brought a
whisper light and extra food and all
this other stuff but you can't carry it
yeah yeah yeah remember Leif was talking
about that yeah yeah first first Patrol
yeah body he had 27 of gran-gran through
them he was ready for World War 3 though
yeah all right yeah cuz it what was the
double doozy was getting acclimated to
being in the 120 degree heat and getting
acclimated to running around the Marine
Corps is out they've been out there for
months
sprinting from corner to corner of the
cover and they've already men to
minimize their gear somewhat mm-hmm and
Lafe shows up he's not only is he a
little heavy or maybe even a lot heavy
but also he's getting acclimated so it's
a double it's a it's a one-two punch all
right this is a good one
while the shaft of your spear should be
long ignored the ground at your peril
when I first read that I was second
myself look at what does that mean
let me ignore the ground mmm here's the
amplification the length of sword to see
your spear as well as the weight lighter
heavier should differ based on three
factors you your enemy and the
battleground so even if your spear is
sufficient not having an understanding
of the different terrain will the will
result in defeat terrain that's what
these that's what he means by ground
yeah
ignore the ground at your peril and this
is something that's very difficult it's
it's something that we don't talk about
even even though I've talked about it
before this podcast for sure mm-hmm
knowing terrain that's what that's what
combat is combat is knowing and
understanding the terrain it's knowing
and understanding the ground it's
understanding land features and
buildings and what angles produce and
and where your patrol should go and
where a good ambush site would be that
is all based on knowing the ground the
terrain is what we call we don't call
the ground we call it the terrain yeah
knowing terrain features micro features
micro terrain
what's this little drawn dead space all
these little things are so important hmm
so that rule absolutely applies to this
day next samurai do not gorge themselves
at banquets eating twice a day is more
than enough amplification samurai must
train themselves to be able to withstand
hunger and to always be on their guard
from days past it was said that two
meals a day is plenty it appears there
were some people eating three times a
day in this era dropping the hammer No
do you eat three meals a day three yeah
thought so
sometimes to what I'm feeling you know
warrior spirit yeah I've actually heard
that I think Euler was the one who told
me that three meals a day
no it wasn't as much as it was the
amount of meals a day it was like the
type of meals you know they were heavy
meals oh okay yeah they'd have a certain
mix like kind of formula but racy diet
yeah and if you notice it it's really
light bananas and encumbers yeah yeah we
made the smoothie for me one time it was
like there was like I want to say cream
cheese in there with watermelon and
banana it was like interesting little
mix but it was good but it was like it's
like a lot of stuff is like cuz you you
know when you get a lot of people coming
in trying to challenge you at the
Academy always gotta be ready yeah so
you can't be like oh I just eat it you
know I don't know I don't like how you
asked me out I do you do what do you eat
in the morning before you work out
nothing yes yeah you don't like to eat
before I trained agree and some people
say oh it's an hour and a half if I
don't eat an hour and a half before I
train I don't even like to eat yeah
three hours I think there might be
psychological I mean everyone that's why
it's about chicken today you got delayed
and I was like hey if I don't eat now
you might get hangry ya know then by the
time we're training tonight oh yeah
I would have to eat when we're done and
all of a sudden it's yeah 45 minutes to
an hour and I'm on the mat I don't like
that stuff in my gut yeah I'd rather not
eat will consider this we're in a real
general way of explaining it if you know
when you eat something your stomach
that'll work your stomach muscles yeah
smooth muscles as opposed to skeletal
muscles by the way smooth muscles they
got to get to work and you know in
enzymes going there all this stuff so
that's taken away from your yeah the
blood flow like all the sudden basically
the resources of your body start going
to your stomach now
and now you want to demand some
resources for the rest of your body well
when you go to Train the stomach's like
hey what about us resources bail from
the stomach little bit stomach feels
upset you might throw up mm-hmm or feel
like it and II almost puke the other day
yeah that's bad all right same subject
that's what I'm gonna go right to it if
a samurai is preparing to step onto the
field of battle just wide to avoid
there's wise to avoid eating anything
other than hot water poured over rice so
that's one way to do it keep
amplification if you eat a lot at a
banquet before a great battle the food
will not have settled by the time the
fighting starts echo Charles called it
if you then were to have your head
chopped off all that food would come out
and it would make a great big mess food
will not pass down the throat of a
coward it appears to you is not common
okay
just next one something a samurai should
never be without is the thing you use to
sharpen your blade a whetstone makes
sense right that's the way you bring
your rings when you're going along
travel yeah if I go for multiple days if
I go if I'm only gonna be gone for like
two or three days mm-hmm I will just use
whatever random pull-up bar I can find
or make or yeah but if I'm going for
five days six days bring the Rings yeah
that rings make a big difference if you
have rings yeah how many workouts you
can do with just rings yeah when you
think about it and I know this from
experience or it's it's all in my
experience it's harder to find something
to do pull-ups on then what you'd expect
you'd think oh yeah I could just do it
like right here
probably can be harder yeah you can't
think so yeah yeah you can do push-ups
anywhere anybody you can do it incline
push-ups you go into the wall the
incline push-ups and you all kinds of
crazy squats and squat histones and jump
squats burpees yeah pull-ups that's why
rings are key and once you have rings
then you can also do ring dips you can
do ring push-ups you can do like
assisted squats if you need them I don't
really do that but you don't need Brooke
I'm not over here bragging about being
able to do empty bodyweight squats but
but you can do everything
once you have pair rigs and you can
usually find a place to do pull-ups
somewhere parking garage they have
little overhanging ledges they have AI
beams you can hang on to you have I hate
to say it cuz I know someone's gonna rip
it and break it and spray water
everywhere but they have sprinkler
systems yeah and that's actually
plumbing system I think actually the
cast iron where they wear the sewage
goes out of a building it's usually a
big pipe and it's hard to do pokes but
it's good yeah I don't think that that's
that's a risk right there and it's
probably against some sort of a rule at
the hotel careful don't tell him I told
you yeah yeah bring Delaney your fault
next is unseemly for a samurai to be
enamored with the flavor of food that is
set down before them
there's best that your meal be a soup
made of boiled water poured over rice
that's how they roll man yeah they're
just like you know what I'm gonna eat
rice with hot water poured over it yeah
otherwise the distraction do you think
that that that sort of asceticism keeps
keeps you tougher yeah in a way it
provides less distraction from your goal
because I can in fitness and you know
like working out body building a lot of
time like that's a factor big-time
because you got to eat a certain amount
to maintain or gain weight and all this
stuff and you know maintain certain you
know macros you know fat levels all this
stuff so you can't just be
going to KFC or wherever you think is
super delicious and just eating and be
like hey this you gotta have like
certain mana like lean stuff and you
can't add a bunch of sauces because
there's extra calories in there you know
all this stuff so yeah if you if you can
endure that kind that kind sit like food
that doesn't necessarily taste that good
yeah you can get to your goal way better
what about Charlie plum me eating two
balls of rice a day for six years yeah
I'm sure that you know that kind of help
them help the later what it's like
accepting of conditions oh great well
that yeah you know like you it's like if
you're if you're used to sleeping on the
floor with like no AC and then whatever
yeah and you know you can go sleep on
someone's couch you can go get rest
pretty much anywhere and that's a good
luxury if especially when you compare it
to a situation where you don't you you
don't have that kind of tolerance you
know you know the kind of worry
you need a certain like softness and
temperature and noise level oh there's B
to fall asleep yeah and then some people
they'll just fall right asleep while
you're talking to them if they want to
kind of thing I can sleep in some I can
sleep real easy on airplanes yeah me too
I get a little crouched up in a little
ball asleep you know what here's what
the here's what he actually says here's
the amplifying information the
profession of the samurai involves being
in an extreme environment therefore
gourmet food is of no benefit to them do
you think that people that just eat
really really high-end food all the time
when they go back to eating normal food
is it is it like are they suffering yeah
a little bit yeah in one way depends how
they regard it you know because you know
cuz well you know it's funny when I was
a kid we'd like I eat a lot of steak now
sure when I was a kid we didn't even eat
steak yeah steak costs a lot of money it
does and and when I was a kid we
hamburgers sure a lot a lot of
hamburgers
yeah and that is what yeah I didn't even
like steak when I got in the Navy I
didn't like steak huh didn't like it I
had to I didn't I just wasn't used to it
you know it took me a couple years
before I started liking state
yeah usually you hit that one stake
that's like prepared perfectly and then
in your mind you're like dang I love
steak now and then even if you get
another steak that wasn't prepared that
perfectly either silver I don't pursue
it happen to me yeah don't it's just
like it I remember eating burgers at
Wendy's though check alright next when
entering a confrontation samurai
shouldn't either look back on the path
traveled nor what is off - left or right
so to me that says prioritize and
execute right and don't be looking
around you you see what you see what you
got a you see what you got to do you got
a confrontation in front of you here's
the amplification from the onset you
should place yourself place your full
concentration on the battle and not
allow your focus to lapse during the
course of the battle the most important
aspects of the battle the most important
aspects of battle are the use of people
and the use of natural geography right
you're a leader you got to use your
people correctly and as I just talked
about terrain using the natural
geography those are the two most
important things now can you get target
fixation yes you can mmm so you can get
so focused that you're if you don't pay
attention what's going on left and right
you might get flanked yeah so you got to
watch out for that one next samurai
should mind neither the heat of summer
nor the cold of winter as they race
through fields and over mountains
exhausting their bodies boom you got a
train in heat and cold you know that's
welcome to the military you freeze and
you sweat that's the way it works yeah
funny Tony Freddie and you kind of
turned me on to just mentally it's more
like putting your mind at a certain in a
certain way we're sure it'll be cold but
it's not about how cold are not cold it
is sure it'll be hot it's not about how
hot or not hot it is and you can't
complain about that stuff and if you
complain that's like that's the part
that's gonna jam you up that's how you
regard him
you cannot complain in the teams here's
what's funny here's this funny I just
you can experience this really easily
let's say you and you and me are out at
the beach and it's warm but out here in
California once the Sun Goes Down it
cool off really quickly you don't have a
sweatshirt with you neither do I yeah
you've got a sweatshirt in your bag
maybe I have one too because actually
this is a contradiction because if I
don't bring one that means I'm not well
prepared yeah so I got one in my bag put
it on take you know you put it on your
waist no I'm not gonna do that I'm not
gonna do that it's gonna leave it you
would not wanna you just want to be TF
as long as you can yeah
just suck it up I don't want I don't
want to you you see me putting on a
sweatshirt indicating to you that I was
cold before now I'm gonna suit I'm gonna
pamper myself not happening what if I
wasn't there I'll put the sweater on
yeah this is straight up right yeah no
there's no denying that yeah that's so
funny because before I thought like that
I would I thought that's so dumb like
put on your sweater you're ruining your
experience or whatever you're at the
beach with your whatever and this
actually happened yesterday at a surf
contest and the clouds came in and it
got cool yeah and my buddy he was all
he's I am gonna go put a sweatshirt on
and I was like oh really then we both
went got her sweatshirt but you let him
do it yeah well he wasn't in the team's
- yeah yes I wasn't just trying to
because there's always that little thing
going on in the team yeah but I kind of
feel like then it goes on in general -
just yes you know yeah fully like like
you get a rock in your shoe just don't
just don't get it out yeah but before
that episode with Tony like I would be
the guy be like no I'm cold
you know I can't relate but after that
for some reason I think it just morphed
in my mind - like you just got PTF and
you kind of get president you know yeah
yeah next as samurai you should take it
upon yourself to spend time playing in
water
not doing so could well result in
disaster that's part one obviously I
agree with that one you got to be in the
water part two samurai should as a
matter of course engage in contests of
strength if you not then your muscles
will become slack hmm obviously I
support that one I don't know if this
guy would just wanted me to read this
book yeah as he knew that I was gonna be
I mean how could you not how does that
not relate to everything that I talk
about all the time yeah be in the water
mmm work out here's what's funny about
this I know he says that the peasants
strengthen themselves with their day to
day labor they also test themselves by
lifting and carrying large stones in
front of the local shrines and did
push-ups in order to build their muscles
and thereby increase their overall
strength however beginning in the migi
era such feats of strength became began
to be ridiculed and the use of rocks
dwindled thus it is hardly a surprise
that the youth of today are weakened
yeah it could and also it's kind of like
that now we're like you know let's say
grip let's say quote-unquote grown
adults right who can lift that rock you
know that's cool though right
why you saying weird voice no because I
would say generally speaking that's kind
of like all you cha children you know
like what do you guys blow oh you know
make fun of that yeah a little feats of
strength to competitions yes what do you
think are the CrossFit Games are though
yeah but you think this World's
Strongest Man is yes the UFC is totally
agree but I think if it's not like
organized and then like presented you
know kind of thing like if me and you
were just cruising at the beach and then
I'm like oh fuck we did me and meanhow
like went to Australia right and we're
like all cruising some downtown we're
filming this this you know this video
and Brad just turned into that 100% was
just mean him so we went from push-ups
he was like hey he's like hey what about
you did the challenge you did in in
Maine yeah back
yes lift it got a shoulder the bag yeah
gravel yeah either way so it's not like
a 200 pound barbell right gravel thing
yeah seeing that's a perfect example but
it makes you strong I think so too
yeah I agree with it good I agree with
it I'm just I'm just saying like if
let's say we're all at a like a part of
barbecue wouldn't like just a vast
variety if you like that's totally
acceptable you know did the 200 pound
bag challenge it's all just guys like
you know but if we were at a barbecue
you know let's say my daughter was a
birthday party or your kettlebells out
right yeah if I challenge you today to a
kettlebell like let's see who can do the
night whatever the 90 pound one or
something at my daughter's birthday
party I think aside from me you and
maybe a handful other guys that are our
direct peers recite from them I think
people would be like you guys are dumb
hmm that's what I think they might be
right
all right next if you allow your samurai
spirit to wither clearly your body will
then follow suit your skin will begin to
stretch as you gain weight part one I
think we all just agree with that yes
how its outright is do you think that
this goes back to the Comfort question
let's take jiu-jitsu at a certain point
where you say I don't really care if I
get caught by this guy or you know what
I'm that guy's training for worlds and
hey if he catches me you know what I
mean yeah yeah I see what you're askin
so so my point is at a certain point you
you you accept you accept it yeah huh I
think that's okay I do think it's okay I
don't I know you don't and it's not an
absolute yes we don't on the door when
the door is you know Hey
it's okay yeah yeah I'm I'm all the
excuses right yeah hey you know these
guys are young and they're training for
the the this competition of that
competition you don't got to get in
there with them yeah when I hear that
knocking I slammed it oh yeah yeah red
flag oh yeah finally actually I open the
door and I choke that bad person out
bring it yeah I dig it and I'm not you
can see what I see I think of that when
you accept that I feel when you accept
it yeah and the other thing that happens
is your ego gets in the way right yes
because what happens is you you don't
wanna you don't want to get tapped out
yeah that's bad yeah so you don't want
to get tapped out so you're not gonna
try yeah and in it right that happens
yeah fully and all yeah different things
that all kind of enter into the equation
so again it it comes back to like why
are you why are you training like why
are you there introduce you or whatever
why either so yeah if this thing what
he's talking about where it's like okay
if you're like letting yourself go if
you're kind of giving up and then
justifying it with in this case oh I'm
old they're training for world and and
that's your your version of giving up
then yeah that's bad
but if it's like let's say you're like
an older guy or whatever and maybe you
kind of lost a step or whatever you know
like like people do when they get older
sometimes and you're like hey you know
this guy's getting nuts if I rise to
that level of intensity I could get hurt
or something like that and it's like in
okay you knows you can be smart Yeah
right yeah for instance if everyone's
doing takedowns and your knees a little
bit tweet yeah yeah you know what
exactly right that's something I need to
check my cell phone sometimes yeah but I
but that's a big one though like when
you when you start like what I'm talking
about cepting yeah well what it is is
you and you allow your samurai spirit to
wither that's what I'm talking about
yeah when you start saying hey you know
what I'd rather still just keep fighting
even though you're getting because the
young buck is coming up and trying and
getting to train more than you and you
got to work and yeah yeah you know what
come tap me out then yeah yeah you still
got I like maintain the spirit yeah
yeah a lot of times when people get
married or they they stopped raining or
whatever and they they blame it on the
marriage or they blame it on their
career some think that it's like ah yeah
you know you know what I do when people
say that people say I'll say oh you know
someone talking to someone they oh you
don't man I used to train a lot and I'm
back oh I mean oh what what happened and
that's we know I got two kids and you
know I was just working a lot I was like
oh yeah I got four kids in their defense
everybody's different yeah if they have
two kids the ofour they're not you and
there aren't you so yes that plus my
wife was good to go yeah yeah it does
make it heart it totally does and it
does make it harder with the kids and a
career and stuff like that it was easy
yeah I agree that's what I was gonna say
it's like creepy slightly valid it's
invalid at the end of the day because
you either kept your warrior your
samurai spirit or you didn't and if you
didn't then you allowed these things
which are true by the way by your as far
as what you're not you but obviously
this person this hypothetical person if
their career or family got in the way
you allowed that to happen it's not easy
totally not easy it's up to you though
at the end of the day I think samurai
are never without a sword on their hip
this means of course that an unarmed
enemy will arm himself so you got always
expect in my mind you always expect that
your opponent is going to be armed
business life whatever you're doing
always expect that your opponent is
ready mm-hmm I always expect them to be
ready next as a samurai you should take
care as to where your feet step as a
matter of course you never want to be
off balance in case the unexpected
occurs well that's pretty
self-explanatory the amplifying
information says samurai have to keep
themselves prepared at all times to
respond
they have to be able to react calmly in
a situation without any panic boom again
does that apply to everything yes it
does no doubt about it
samurai who are not aware of the things
they should know our like cats that do
not know how to catch mice not aware of
things they should know you know
samurais should be continuously thinking
about military manners matters fail to
do this at your peril those that serve
in the military should be in a
continuous state of thinking of warfare
to be negligent in this will result in
failure and defeat you know I told us I
tell us the young military people that I
work with mm-hmm that this is your job
this is your profession and you got to
do everything you can to master it and
that means what is being sent right here
continuously thinking about military
matters matters any samurai who spends
too much time playing ball koto guitar
plucking the mouth harp or playing the
flute are liable to become a coward and
here it says those in the military
should never become overly and fashioned
it infatuated with diversionary games
okay
now at some point I'd like to get better
at guitar but apparently next wall a
samurai may be clumsy about some things
the spear the horse and the bow should
not be among them I like that mm-hmm
this one is key samurai should make a
habit of regularly listening to tales of
military combat and rely on the learning
found therein this is a blatant look for
Jocko podcasts yeah I think yeah
and here's the amplifying information by
listening to such tales regularly it
will keep them fresh in your mind when
actual combat arises they will be of
benefit boom boom and I've definitely
got that feedback I've gotten all kinds
of good feedback about that from guys in
the military mean that they can relate
cuz I'm telling you the stories that we
tell over and over again they're stories
that happen they're real face
fire and maneuver there's people acting
weird there's the enemy doing things
these things are real yeah and is
definitely helpful the more you I wish I
would have known more when I was in I
would have been infinitely better mmm
you have enough of a focus on it though
yeah kind of goes for everything to you
like because it kind of keeps your whole
um like approach to life in that that
battle frame you know yeah so everything
you know like it gives you different
perspectives I talk about this all time
if if you learn the armbar right from
the mount yes you learn it one way but
you don't realize man there's there's
infinitely different ways to do it you
can get it from the guard you can get it
from the bottom position you can get it
from a cross side you can get although
you can get the arm lock from all these
different positions yeah and every time
you see it from a different angle you
get better at all of them yeah so every
time you see a military situation from a
different angle from a leadership
perspective from the ground trooper
perspective from the cold from the hot
from the desert from the mountains you
learned something makes you better at it
yeah so it's so looking at things
through that friend you know whatever it
may be whether it be military history
whatever you're always kind of looking
at things in that way yeah yeah like
this we had this guy we call him uncle
Jill he's my friend of the family
in Hawaii you know wow yeah and he's he
was a really good artist but he used to
climb trees and take us just tree
climbing I know random hippie thing
actually me talking about it right now
but it was super good fun but this guy
he'd always be like there's a there's an
instinctive of climbing right PE humans
have an instinct to climb things yeah he
seems like yeah okay and he air it would
be weird cuz he'd pull out that climbing
thing
I could climb up there you know that
okay like dang if you kinda have these
like looking at things through frames
that are that are useful you know like I
think like but it's like man you can
figure a lot of things out that you a
lot of people wouldn't figure out yeah
you know like I know videos like that
for sure black thing that's like a good
shot how that you know no one's don't
care that's just a beach or whatever but
I was a young enlisted guy and I had a
friend that would uh you'd kind of like
your friend like like to climb things
this guy would jump off there Uncle Joe
Uncle Joe would climb things this guy
would job yeah yes and we were on this
obstacle course this random obstacle
course and he climbed he also liked to
climb but then he got to the top of this
thing he was probably let's call it 18
feet not sure and I'm um I slid down the
rope and the other guy slid down the
rope and the chief that we were with
slid down the rope sure and I look up an
eagle and he's got kind of like a
puzzled look on his face why you got a
jumper the jumpers got like a curious
look on inquisitive yeah and he says I
think I could jump down this steep and I
go do it and the chief goes don't do it
and he said I think I could make it and
and I said do it and the chief says
don't do it hmm and I go ten bucks
chief goes shut up Joe go don't do it
and I go 20 bucks
and he goes shut up and right is he
saying that the jumper Jones
did it and he made it jump like 18 feet
down just landed PLF PLF yeah parachute
landing fall oh wait you break you fall
down oh okay that's almost like a judo
fall but with your yeah yeah like it
disperses yeah the way he did it it's
good man
good in a good-hearted way uh-huh nah
man you could have gotten hurt no
two-bit your fault yeah all that kind of
thing
it would have been yeah I know I know
you knew his jumpin weakness yeah his
addiction to jumpin and you exploited it
next samurai should keep in their hearts
the fact that they only die once
forgetting this will result in failure
samurai who forget this is the this is
so this this one's a little bit tricky
for me to understand samurai should keep
in their hearts the fact they only die
once forgetting this will result in
failure and the amplification on this
one says samurai who forget that they
can die at any time and in any place
could end up in humiliating failure in
other words throwing your body into the
river and relying on fate to determine
if you float to the shallows if you love
your life too much you will always end
in failure so this is what I found
interesting about this one there's a
dichotomy here the dichotomy to me is if
if you care too much about being alive
then you won't take any risk and you'll
be too scared and you'll that's gonna be
bad yeah so that that's that we know
that that one's bad so we know we get
that one if you love your life too much
you will always end in failure maybe not
always but it's gonna definitely play a
role you'll be too cautious you won't
take any risk you'll be scared that
one's gonna be you'll hesitate yeah so
we get that one the keeping your hearts
that you'll only die once okay so that
means to me okay so you can die at any
time I'm gonna make it worth it in my
mind make it dope yeah make it dope okay
and then this whole thing about okay let
me read it board forward throwing your
body into the river and relying on fate
to determine if you float to the
shallows I don't know to me that could
be taken two ways and I think they're
both okay number one is is like hey
don't just throw just just jump don't
just jump into the river and sea and let
fate decide if you're gonna make I don't
know you
hair and you train and you're ready hmm
the other way it can be taken is you
know what you can't control everything
you got to go jump into the river and if
you if you're meant to make it you're
gonna make it even one of those can
possibly set your mind at ease and what
I've you know you've heard me talk about
fear to turn away the warrior kid right
yeah way the warrior kid what happens
you prepare everything you can but then
eventually you got to jump and see if
the water difficult current takes you to
the shallow water again yeah that's the
way it's gonna be yeah so that's the way
I took that one yeah I read a lot into
that one I think the first one just
because the other one would add kind of
additional X like requirement required
explanation like you're saying is you
agree with preparing I think I thought
yeah yeah I agree with her parent I
think the of the two that you just said
the first one I think makes more sense
to me that that's what he meant so
you're you're thinking that he meant to
prepare the best of your ability yeah
all right like you like it's kind of
like you only have one life and if
you're gonna die make it legit don't be
dying trying to cross the river you
better die doing something big time you
know kind of thing there's one more
little addition that I believe that Eric
actually added on here yeah this is his
note it says the line about throwing
your body into the river and relying on
fate to determine if you floated the
shallows is very famous it's not that
famous because I googled it and I
couldn't find it now he says enter
battle fleek fully committed and perhaps
you will emerge alive at the end hmm I
think that makes some sense from it's
for me prepare the best your ability
yeah be fully committed and then don't
worry about what the end is gonna come
because you can't control everything
yeah I think we're good I think now this
one I had to I had to dig on this a
little bit too samurais study a great
many things however the single focus of
their learning is deaf and then the the
amplifying information here you
while samurai do intensive training and
study a variety of topics what it all
boils down to is seeking death so that
that kind of that one I tried to figure
out what that meant or at least what it
means to me and I think to the most
positive way I could use seeking death
right are you really seeking death is
that what you're trying to do well no if
you're you're not helping the cause if
you're seeking death right you don't
want to die that's not our goal it's an
occurrence that could happen in a matter
of fact it's gonna happen all of us but
the way I look at it is what we're
trying to learn we're trying to
understand and masters death and the
fear of death mmm if we can get over
that little little hurdle right then
you've mastered that and once you're
actually saying I'm going forward I'm
prepared then we're good or it could be
also just like just you know as far as
seeking challenges go you want to seek
one challenge then you want to seek a
bigger challenge yeah but yeah that's
what I mean though so you're pursuing
the ultimate challenge that beats you
know like what your brunch Point Break
come on beau yes yes there you go where
you know Bodhi he's looking for the the
50-year storm remember same thing so
he's like I'm gonna be there and all the
stuff he's always trying to push the
limit all these things bank robbery
skydiving all this stuff and you know
finds the 50-year storm knows it 100%
knows it in fact I was kind of like his
escape from the law mmm catch one of
those ways dies everyone knew it did he
really die with her sequel where he
lived he died it was all kind of it I
guess nothing Missy there's room for a
secret exactly right but it was well
they remade the same movie yeah do you
see that one no not bad yes I see what
they're doing there um you know a little
bit too like you could tell they're
trying to target maybe some teenagers or
something like that but not bad set
through it glad it wasn't a waste of
time
yeah all right this one again had to had
to dig a little deeper on this one if
you were to ask what can what is it that
concerns a samurai
the answer is I want to live I want to
live okay so to break that down a little
bit I look at the word concerns and what
concerns means is worries or troubles
it's not yeah I don't think they're
using them more like oh that concerns me
yeah like like it's not saying hey what
what what concerns me or what I'm
thinking about
it's what I'm worried about what I'm
worried about is someone that's saying I
want to live I want to live that's what
they're worried about
yeah because someone that's saying I
want to live and I think you can apply
this to a lot of stuff let's take
negotiation right you get negotiation
with somebody if you're saying I want to
win this deal on this deal I want your
out of position of weakness yeah yeah so
even in business you can't have the
position if I want to live I want to
live up-what but I want to score this
deal yeah I want to make I want to get
this deal done like no you know if
you're actually negotiating you need to
be able to walk away from the deal and
say no we're done I'm out strangely they
say the same thing about picking up
girls same thing yes if you're all I
hope I get this girl help get this girl
that girl doesn't want to be with a guy
that is British right dude
yeah the amplification here says in
answer to the question what do samurai
worry about the answer is having the
desire to extend their own life is
something worth regretting samurai who
value their own lives are not worth a
farthing yeah so we've got that's I
think you need to be able to set aside
that well I think it applies to
everything I think so do that applies to
everything yeah if you're soakin sexy
like in jujitsu you're totally concerned
about winning and not tapping out yeah
you're not gonna learn yeah and even
worse you're not gonna compete you're
naughty
I'm not gonna do well yeah and you're so
apprehensive and yeah you got a place a
lot for sure here's a good one it is
important to understand that should the
mirror in a samurai's heart be unclouded
then the opponent will be clearly
reflected in it good one
amplification any samurai whose will is
fom can be described as having a mind
that is unclouded so if you will is firm
think about that if your will is firm
you can be described as having a mind
that is unclouded in such a state the
strength or weakness of the opponent
will be perfectly reflected next samurai
cast off thoughts of both life and death
their mind is set on moving forward
amplification samurai do not dwell even
for a moment on whether they live or die
fulfilling their mission requires
samurai to advance it is what they do
best what they were made for yeah that
is I think that that one breaks down to
being able to clear your mind on what
happened the last go-round right not
worried about the future not worried
about the black when you're doing
something like if you're competing you
make a mistake you have to put that out
of your brain completely yeah and you
need to do okay the mistake happened or
you did something great you can't jump
up and down and be all happy about that
you need to just clear your mind and
yeah keep the mind empty yeah you can't
get freaked out about the next shot or
the last shot yeah we learn that in
shooting like this is something you see
all the time when we're shooting we do
little basically when you're shooting in
the team's everything is a competition
sure and you'd see a guy you're shooting
head plates and they'd have six head
plates in a row which is a steel plate
about the size of a hit and you got to
shoot a minute and we shoot it you
instantly know if you hit a riskless
ping ping
Pingping mm-hmm and if you see a guy
that can't put the last one out of their
head yeah you know it's mad change it's
bad guy that's really good he'll miss
and just he'll dismiss and he doesn't
even think about yeah you're here you're
here ping ping ding ding ding ding ding
you just ya know factor yeah it's it is
the proverbial choking you know yeah
look at the end like why is this guy
choking at the end I'm just killing it
before I'm can train your mind to do
that yeah I can train your mind do that
so where you're just and actually when I
be shooting a lot I could get to that
point and then if I'm not shooting a
bunch I would lose that and almost like
a big pink get frustrated you're
shooting regularly you get that you get
past that and the older you get and the
more you do it the more you can just say
nope don't care you know what a phrase
would would would always work with me
when someone like if you had a coach or
something where you know in football
you'd have this where like you'd be
winning the whole game mm-hmm you know
and in the fourth quarter it's like oh
my god we just run out the clock or I
don't you have that feeling and guys
that joke a lot of time and that's not
to mention the other team is thinking
the exact opposite we got nothing to
lose we're gonna hear them we're gonna
take risks we're gonna do all this you
know so that's why guys can win or teams
can win at the last minute even though
they've been getting their ass kicked
old yellow game fights kind of like that
too but favorites seem to have like more
of a will I don't know for some reason
but either way either way I don't know
but the phrase that would always help me
as if someone would just put in my ears
and say finish strong just say finish
strong strong like yeah it's almost like
though or they'll say punch it through
or something you know something like
that that indicates don't let up at the
end mentally you know just go just keep
pushing the way you thought that is a
little bit different than getting
distracted by what just happened yeah
but because they say yeah it is a little
bit different but in it's like what's
your critical role when you played
football what was it
we're trying to do each play were you
weren't you a receiver yeah okay so
let's say you missed their catch that
you should have caught you had to be
able to put that out of your head right
so it's just a mental state where it's
like finish strong it's finished strong
in your mind you know so yeah don't
worry about your inside get this all the
time man woman when I'd win a match and
then I'd win another one you know Judy
you gotta win like matches to the file
after two matches I just start feeling
this pressure like it's almost like my
to match win streak is about to come to
an end it's all like the pressure and
then you win one more and then the
pressure is even on more is weird it's
like I wish I did I wish I was done it
is weirdo does but if someone would say
something along the lines of finished
strong it would just cure the whole
thing because you're thinking about all
these mentally throw you off I don't
know the pressure but you could somebody
say something to you that would make you
freak out even more yeah oh yeah what a
freaking out more if someone said oh you
got this or if someone says hey at least
you made it this far would you then back
off because what were you doing with
kids it would do you know like that I
mean like I got kids you got kids - yeah
but you know when you got kids that are
doing something competitive
yeah like jiu-jitsu a wrestling and
let's say they're winning and and you
could tell them hey you've done good so
far go out there and have fun which is
cool or you could say hey you need to
focus more now but because you these
people are gonna be getting tougher yeah
both of those to me would throw Mia
because when you say just relax you've
made it this far that tells them that
it's okay they're not to be too checked
out you know so it depends on what their
state of mind is to go into that that
comment or to the situation how much to
the time I feel like I want to tell
people either people I'm coaching well
know I'm what I shouldn't say that one I
want to tell my kids relax go out there
have fun go out there and have a good
time yeah because I think that is easier
on their brains and and to what your
point was earlier when people let loose
and they they don't feel the pressure
they tend to perform better at her you
know
yeah I agree with that fully but if it's
like if that's like kind of the
underlying attitude like relax have fun
regardless of what Matt first match last
finals match whatever then yes I think
so
but if it's like come on you got this
will do you snooze you lose and then
right when he gets to the final then you
say okay yeah that's me this far so it
slow your Sinus bad I think he can be
better than how they take it but if they
take it like that I didn't relax yeah
I said go out there and have a go go out
there and do what you do I say that okay
so if you say you made it this iconic
MMA fight to be like hey do what you do
that's good to say if someone told me
that go do what you do that would really
be incarnate don't do what you do yeah
that's good stuff to say to me this but
anything to put pressure on me like if
you do this you win like you know like
one more match and that's it no it's
interesting like with coaching MMA if
you would get a guy in and get it into a
guy's head do not get taken down and
they'd go in there without you you'd be
really hard to take that person down
yeah and when and you'd say hey soon if
you get taken down as soon before you
even get on the ground you're getting
back up you get that people with that
mind is that going and it'll be really
hard for someone to take him down
holding up because even panicking
yeah let me basically pick up get you
know yeah so interesting here's a good
one and this is actually the last one
fittingly not engaging in any form of
study will cause your mind to wander
this route will result in your spirit
becoming unfocused and the amplification
there is nothing wrong with daydreaming
but if you study your spirit will become
focused on and shape to deal with a
certain thing that shape will then
become lost in turn there is a song that
goes the drifting and becoming lost is
what the mind does it becomes your
spirit the mind of your spirit do not
allow your mind to do this
and yeah I think that that's that's
something that we actually talk about
all the time in fact that may be the
very purpose of me doing everything that
we do which is you know studying and
learning and to go back to the question
that that Eric the translator posed to
me can any of the rules in this book
apply to modern warfare as I said not
only do they apply to modern warfare
they apply to life and the thing is
there's nothing really new here right
just like an armlock there's nothing
really new here but that doesn't mean
that there's nothing really new here
there's always something new
huit sure we've heard these lessons
before right we've heard them from dick
winners we've heard them from Bob
Hoffman and we've heard them from
General Patton and hackworth and we
heard him from wooden leg and I said
this on the first podcast that we did
the first podcast that we did I said you
know what to do you know to be balanced
and you know to workout and you know not
to be gluttonous with food and you know
you shouldn't sleep late and you know
you should keep things clean and
organized and you know that your
struggles now will be rewarded in the
future so you must endure endure endure
the hardship endure the suffering endure
the pain of discipline endure the pain
of discipline so that in the future you
can have the reward and we know what
that reward is the reward for discipline
is freedom
and I think that is all I've got for
tonight
so echo
speaking of rewards and freedom and
trying to get better do you have any
suggestions on maybe some ways to get
better for people here ways that might
also at the same time simultaneously
support this podcast if people want it
sure do something like that you want to
also I think it is important and
beneficial to add that you know when you
endure the suffering pain that's
metaphors for the most part sometimes
it's real pain oh yeah and suffering
real real but you do that enough and you
get used to it and to the point where
you kind of like require it in a way
like you kind of want it like you know
how I used to go on like you know like a
strict diet and I'd be hungry a lot but
at the same time if the diet would be
really effective with a good workout
program and then so when I go off the
program you kind of you know you feel
kind of almost like for like a better
term just like toxic like hard just a
second you know yeah you almost I kind
of Miss that hunger and the you know the
because you can't associate the hunger
that you always have with like being in
good shape and perform point it kind of
like that's an example of like how it
can be you know you know like eating a
lot I don't know it's weird you don't
even have to amplify it just do it
yeah like when you're on the program
yeah it kind of feels good that you're
on the program you're suffering for sure
there's something I quote unquote
suffering there but it feels good and
especially when you do you know it's
funny when you think about the opposite
of that which is when you're off the
program yes and you feel like I'll rap
yeah and you and yet what do you do to
make yourself feel better what do you do
instead of going on the program instead
you go to the you go to the sleeve of
Oreos yeah the answer
yeah that's like the answer yeah that's
a good that's the instant gratification
yeah right
it's we're opposite of struggling now
yeah you're you're you're not enduring
now you're not facing the pain of
discipline now you're looking for a
short term rewards so that's why that's
why I said said it in the book I said in
the book the field manual right like
when you're on the path it's it's easier
to stay on the path I won't you fall off
the path man yeah people people just
gets they go to the downward spiral yeah
that's like you fall for the trick and
those I have mentioned this is a trick
your might feel like if you like that
you're getting it is fans I names you
know when you uh you fall off the path
you say when you feel like crap cuz
you're off the program and the fact that
you're off the program aside from just
your physical physicality you feel like
crap so you got alleviate that feeling
so you go to something that's gonna give
you pleasure but guess what wrong
pleasure you in short term when you need
it long term yeah you know so that's
what you do that is a good a good thing
I do that when let's say don't feel I've
been traveling been eating crap the way
to get back on the way to feel good
again is just to hit yourself let me get
some it's true
get some do good you have a good couple
base like you know in the in the Field
Manual I've got these various workouts
and there's some of those in there that
are just core not Korres and abs because
we call it good but but core programs
that are fundamental yeah and I kind of
know where I'm at on them and even if
I'm not gonna go in there and do a
record performance mm-hmm
it'll put me back on track it'll metal
it'll clean my system yeah mentally and
physically yeah and that's good well I
used to do this thing where um you know
if you're you have a girlfriend
you get in a fight or something like
that or they break up with you or
whatever whatever you know something
that makes you in a bad mood for
whatever reason they should go to the
gym and do uh eat like shoulders or
chest workouts I mean that would give
like a really
really hard painful pump you know that
kind like I don't know 1215 reps like a
minute in between do like eight sets of
those massively pumped for some reason I
just feel way better that's the same
thing that's what I'm talking about
yeah the way if you can give yourself
for me you got your you got some
workouts that are just fundamental I
don't know what there's their prior name
for like medicine
yeah medicine new yeah medicine some
medicine workouts you know you gotta
have some of those medicine workouts
that just put you back on the yeah I
have a path yeah and then you know what
do a fast do 24 hours do 24 hours you
feel you feel good I'm telling you yeah
you good yeah I'll do like 15 now
actually pretty often too and you're
right strangely you're right Lud yeah I
just read another article I read two
articles because people people tweet
them to me
yeah one of them was about intermittent
fasting would guess what it's good for
you yeah and then the other one was
about this whole depletion of will isn't
not true yeah well they what I was right
all scientists were wrong what they are
saying I think with what you're saying I
think there's like a you're saying it's
straight up wrong what there's no no
there's I just read an article today
that it's wrong yeah that this idea of
the depletion of you know if you if you
have to resist this chocolate chip
cookie then within in 20 minutes you
won't be able to resist the cake because
you just can't resist that much yeah
it's a lie
it's in there there's proving now that
it's not true yeah not true
yeah I feel like that's a psychological
state so I might vary from individual
but what I'm saying is if you if you're
on the program yeah and you had some
medicine in the morning yeah yeah I'm
telling you that it's easier to hold the
line the more you hold the line the
easier it is to hold the line
that's that truth yeah that's the truth
you know get some
speaking a whole little old Emmaline and
the truth by the way Jacque has some
supplements Jaakko supplements krill oil
the main one and joint warfare so joint
warfare glucosamine and chondroitin and
curcumin which is the other there's it's
not just glucosamine and chondroitin
yeah this Curt cumin
yes what is that it's more goodness
some stuff to wage war fare against
joint inflammation pain urination
yeah so and that's a big deal cuz again
I'm gonna say I said it before but I
think this is critical I mean me you
know I'm sure there's like supplements
that'll help you build your muscles if
you're into building my I'm sure there
is but really if you can maintain your
joints especially if you do get to
pushing weights any kind of like so I
like an elbow dynamic movement yeah you
know cuz you joints take those that that
brunt and they degenerate over time
oh they do is that what's happening to
you you're generating huh yeah no no I
dig it and the this is one of the krill
oil thing I'm not embarrassed cause it's
kind of a funny story at my expense in a
little bit it's not funny funny but it
is that I was like did to my father in
here no you know the truth yeah I'm like
over here pushing krill oil like in life
I mean ya know um Brian his name is
brighter and I we went to the retreat in
Maine or Brian the black belt they came
yes I'm sure
um so I kind of keep contact with him
he's like he's like hey do you have any
like what's the cool supplements or
whatever I was like right you know and I
sent him some some of mine and he was I
think it the report back I was like the
other day but nonetheless in life I'm
straight-up pushing it like I tell Greg
about it all the time I don't think I
don't think here maybe give him
something I don't know but it's like you
know the can you get benefits for
something I mean you're like pushing it
on other people some people do it with
regarding Lee
sure just various things you know books
music why don't we do that with music
like if you like my me you know like
I'll be like hey listen to this song
it's the best song and then like you
don't like it and I'm actually mad at
you or you're mad at me cuz you don't
like it why yeah because I just don't
like your music
ya know Bravo I think we can't equate it
to our identity you know in a way yeah
it's kind of what I do with crude oil
part of my identity you know it's part
of my joints an identity ed can tell you
that and joint Morpher good ones also oh
wait I didn't tell you where you can get
this joint more fair and super cruel or
gin mein kampf click on the top to the
labs actually it's on the front page -
it's on jaw closed or - by the way jaw
closed or calm but yeah this room you
can get it if you want it if you want it
a lot of people been asking for
subscription like a recurring yeah so
you can get it every month that's what
it should be
I know ya know because we'll get it set
up yeah you could use until the last
three pills or it's even six you take
the three like dang I only have three
laughs and I gotta take this tomorrow
yeah after tomorrow you know two days
shipping unless you got an overnight
shipping situation
yeah there's this you don't want to do
that to yourself no you don't you
actually filled the Hogan back going on
yes good idea thank you
John Cole in Pete also there's some good
keys on there chuck was a key chuckles a
rash guard we'll start with that
American hands I've worn it many times
can I talk about nineteen percent
improvement in performance
I got tapped out by Andy so so far no
got tapped I'll pay you Tues yeah maybe
I still I don't know any different than
normal right yes but I couldn't resist
nineteen I'm just saying the girls do
out I can't confirm really yeah but but
if you remember cuz you Murphy remember
I was wearing one of our rash guards
mm-hmm small action bigger yeah and I
kind of got got after them right and in
so really in theory you're 19 plus and
mining 19 plus kind of canceled itself
okay really but I felt like maybe if you
got 19 I felt like that day I had like
26% 1326 yeah you were bringing it like
you had 26 cuz you weren't typically
don't wear that right you don't really
wear a skirt much you weren't happy on
the final guillotine no I think you look
Cobra you literally said I saw that
coming
yeah and that was one of those comments
that was meant to kind of deflate my
victory you know like you saw coming and
it was so obvious and it was just like
you I just got lucky and blah blah blah
and I just I just said yeah definitely
I'm not really Telegraph about what you
got I can't believe how pathetic it was
yeah you want me to give you a breakdown
of your guilt your guillotine Cobra
which i think is even more so than the
guillotine like you have such a good way
to get it you're one of those guys that
like you're probably walking like right
now you're thinking about guillotine
right now yes that's what I think that's
what it feels like a lot so it's like
when you go for it it just lands
perfectly it's not the kind where you
know maybe not know yep no adjustments
so it's gotten to the point over
literally like what a day like almost a
decade of training with you and that
thing getting sunk in that efficiently
on my own I don't want your not that far
from the truth yeah it's like my body
like knows like hey we've been here
before that's what my brain is almost
like I can feel my brain as a separate
entity test for my body sometimes if I
get you in a guillotine yet you go crazy
trying to defend it and then like and
you'll get out and the next one I'll be
like yeah he's going down yeah it's like
man I don't want that beef again because
what I what I have to do to get out of
that first one is a pro I can't do yeah
it's not worth it that's exactly what it
is and I think that's how my whole body
reacts when I feel like it's sunk in
man this again we've been down this road
same outcome you know my body's used to
that outcome so it just kind of
accommodate sit that's what it feels
like and I think that's part of what I
meant but it's like I think all that
coming I think your body is okay with me
getting you I think so too I don't like
the fact that it's like that I don't
like yeah I think I think talking about
it might help
or it might straight-up not yeah rash
guards jeez made in America which is
awesome so that's awesome
yeah everyone should know that and they
make them like make them yes'm yes they
don't like shipping some stuff and then
hey guys okay are we starting to make
yeah even though it's been you know yeah
they make or make it from the thread and
the give the keys good think he's good
hard these videos coming out yeah
without the origin but I mean video
Megan I got make him confused with with
Amanda by the way a whole long story I
won't go and do it right now nonetheless
videos out making made the video that's
a good one
actually you kind of made the video do
you mean now
nonetheless Jacques gives out other keys
on origin all good I got two other ones
so three or gingy's altogether me it's
the only keys all everywhere I think
unless someone else can make the own
their own material in America and you
know provide the same everything then
hey maybe maybe not but just saying
doesn't right now that's how it is also
kettle bells all right I'm gonna keep
you updated on my kettlebell situation
I'm addicted I'm addicted to him
collecting and doing them so I got one
more that's the Cyclops from on it
mmm-hmm the designer one no no what do
you call it the regulation regular ones
and none of those anyway Cyclops I think
is forty something pounds I only got one
I'm getting out that one anyway
the good thing about these is they are
balanced because a lot of times and from
what I hear I don't know but from what I
hear like a lot of the designer ones
they're not balanced
Sumer Singh anyway these are balanced
and that's one the ones I use and I'm
addicted to the workouts start slow with
these and when you do it though are you
still doing a lot of kettlebells yeah I
do decent amount of cannibals yeah doing
some Turkish get ups the other day yeah
right I didn't get that I thought I was
gonna get really into Turkish get ups
but I did it a few times and just it
didn't it didn't stick you know you know
understand stuff just sticks even though
it was cool I eat you know what it was I
did it with the 35 pound one that I did
with a 54 pound one and I was like dang
this this is a good exercise hard and
then I went online to look up exercises
and then there's ones with guys doing it
with 185 pounds I mean it and maybe I
just got discouraged mmm I got
encouraged oh I see that
oh yeah yeah huh you take it it's like a
challenge yeah yeah outlook is different
anyway when you do these kettlebells if
you want the cool ones to me kettlebells
are dope but if you want an extra dope
ego to on it calm slash choco get your
kettlebells there
just look at them we got like one's
heavy ones I say start light but hey
whatever your level is you know get them
all so when you get your copy of what is
the the translated hundred rules of war
yes again yeah which I'm pronouncing
wrong sorry
yeah see and that's been really Eric and
okay so I put these books all these
books if you didn't know already
I'm say it again I put all the books on
our website chocolate podcast.com and
this is for this very reason Jocko
doesn't know how to pronounce some of
this stuff no especially the Japanese
stuff you know he comes to me for help I
help it's not a smooth process is what
I'm saying so I tried to smooth it out a
little bit
choco pop calm on the top says books
from the episodes click on there look
this episode 101 boom from episode 101
the hundred rules of war don't even
though there's only 97 them and if you
want to get some other book you can
still click through yeah and support the
podcast yeah and if you buy a book that
is completely off of what we would
normally talk about yeah
like for like what I don't know
something that's not about war The Lion
the Witch and the Wardrobe yeah if you
go to buy that book yeah you can just
click it still supports the podcast for
doesn't have to be the but but when you
buy it yeah just click anywhere you're
not buying a book even if you're buying
clubs golf clubs duct tape lawn mower
grocery bag holders mmm
even though I don't recommend that stuff
if you carry grocery bags you carry them
with your hands both hands Oliver too by
the way
anyway yeah click through there so on
our website joke about yeah some good
way to support also subscribe to the
podcast see if you haven't already on
iTunes stitcher Google Play
Spotify is that a right I don't use a
lot of that modifies not you can't get
vinyl well I don't think you can get it
but there's a bunch of any podcasting
platform
I don't think Spotify is one of them we
had requests for Spotify because then
you could play it on Alexa but I can
Alexa right now you can say Alexa play
the latest jockle podcast actually in
not to split hairs but it's called
Amazon echo alexis is just the name you
say yeah but is what you say yeah so
that's what I said no you said you can
get it on Alexa Oh looks like technique
efforts I just want us to go in correct
and insane and doing the right thing
that's all nonetheless subscribe if you
haven't already either put it this way
I'm not saying subscribe I'm saying
subscribing is a good way to support
also on YouTube subscribe to the YouTube
channel put some videos on there
excerpts not as many excerpts as I did
last week this week because I got I
learned this new video thing we talked
about earlier I won't go into it but
right here it's pretty technical but I
wound up getting like obsessed with it
so like fur I think it was like 11 hours
a day for three days I'm making this
clip that's like three seconds long
honey so I didn't get to the excerpts is
what I'm saying but as a result I think
there's I think the next video that our
release is gonna have some new things to
it might be something that only I'm
noticing maybe
maybe not but nonetheless that's gonna
be how it is either way the point there
is subscribe to YouTube that's a good
way to support yeah I want to do a
YouTube live figure out how to do that
yeah it's not that hard
whoa so let's do why just a YouTube
random yeah yeah
like a Facebook live yeah you too yeah
cuz I think it'd be cool to be stored on
YouTube instead of stored on Facebook
right yeah I think it's just a matter of
yes it doesn't matter ultimately it's
just a video yeah but if it's a if it's
stored on on YouTube people can go back
and be reading it and whatever and well
I started watching it if it's on
Facebook its way buried in some random
yeah yeah your feet yeah what do you
call it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
timeline whatever yeah yeah yeah there's
ox on that one nonetheless YouTube
that's a good one to subscribe got some
other videos aside from just the video
version of this podcast that's the good
that's the main reason I think to
subscribe if you're interested in that
kind of stuff and you can cite you know
you can get a notification if you want
you don't need it but you can go on also
jock with the store it's called
chocolate or chocolate or Tom got some
new stuff on there straight-up
rash guards hoodies are up I know I've
been saying it but they're up though is
one of hats got some hats I
I'm putting beanies on there oh yes
those that's good yes yes I hope your
thick beanies they're uh regular I
didn't know there's nothing I've been
you know doing some research this is a
good beanie ok from all I kinda
extrapolated all the you know the advice
online and these are the good ones also
some new rash guards kay the new rash
guard is a rash guard that says small
action on one side big reaction on the
other side when I work for the first
time healing Taylor
mmm-hmm said he didn't know he didn't
know the layers but he saw it he was
like the essence of
jiu-jitsu I was like oh because it is
right this is my action be creation so
what we're hoping for yeah interesting
cueing judo Kealing yeah he knew he
knows about the way also uh some women's
stuff on there which is cool I think
some patches on their shirts I'm gonna
have a new shirt coming out oh I don't
have a new shirt you have a new Cheryl
coming out do I know what it is
nope no interesting not yet a lot of
times I'll get input from the online
people from the people and I kind of you
know I love most of the time it's like
one-off things you know like whoo I
heard chocolate is one thing this is one
time back then I really liked it we
would make a great shirt kind of thing
and although they're usually right a lot
of times I'm thinking maybe that might
not translate into your real picky and
twosies or what I'm hearing yeah put it
this way a lot of people have to hit me
with it
broker and this was one of those I've
actually mentioned it before it's called
back to the book I think it's coming up
anyway that one's coming out too
chuckles store Jaakko store.com take a
look at the stuff on there if you see
something you like it's something also
psychological warfare on all of our this
is what psychological warfare is on all
of our journeys I'm going back to
journey someone requested some of the
other day and it was actually better
than campaign or journey but I forget
what it was yeah so it's better just not
that much better no it's better but I
can't remember it I see a lot of stuff
that's true you do see a lot of stuff
well on our campaign against weakness
journey everyone's well we'll run into
roadblocks points of weakness hopefully
less than more more times than that we
don't we don't resume saying not very
clearly hopefully not very often but one
the un-- infrequent time comes where you
run into those weaknesses you said I'm
on infrequent time but it's cool I know
we know what you mean bro the nut
frequent yeah the rare time that you run
into weaknesses do not worry because
psychological warfare is an album with
tracks that helps you write through that
most situations pretty much all
situations really waking up early
skipping workouts procrastination
staying on the program diet why is all
this stuff a lot of stuff bunch of
tracks on there and it's Jocko telling
you pragmatically ways that you can
practice weight practical right
practical meaning you can practice these
things it's not just some philosophical
/ inspirational stuff I would say do
yeah it's more do practical it's kind of
the team word for it but nonetheless
practical advice coming directly from
chaco directly into your ear on why you
shouldn't give in to these weaknesses
it's like a little spot in your campaign
that's what psychological warfare is
it's a good one you're real good on the
way that we look number one spoken word
album on iTunes for about nine months
and it finally got beaten out by another
album it was freedom Field Manual which
is people keep asking me it's available
as an album with tracks on iTunes Amazon
music Google Play and other mp3
platforms also on Amazon you can get
chocolate white tea what's good about
jakka white tea is if you drink jockle
white tea you are guaranteed to 100% to
be able to deadlift eight thousand
pounds minimum minimum I don't care
what's your body weight 125 cool
eight thousand pound deadlift so they
guarantee like that we're looking pretty
good you try it out there's some books
weigh the warrior kid by the way I just
finished where the warrior kid book
number two what the whole thing or the
draft The Drowsy I mean there's gonna be
some edits yeah the story the story is
completely done it's a good story by my
nephew read it and he said it's better
than the first one that's saying a lot
because the second definitely a little
message and you know his message said
hey uncle Jocko that's what it said and
he's in fifth grade so it's a pretty
accurate assessment we're assuming from
him good please study but the book
number one is out right now and it is
the book that you wish
again I wish I had it when I was a kid
who didn't have it no one had hadn't
written it yet no hadn't learned the
lessons so if you want to give a kid a
better life get in this book also
extreme ownership check it out new
edition is coming out matter of fact let
me rephrase that new edition is out it
is available right now it has a new
forward in it where we talk about kind
of what we've seen since the book came
out it has color pictures in it new
pictures it has echos name in it why is
echos name it echos name and isn't it
because we took cue a from the podcast
about leadership and put the really
important questions and answers in there
so you can refer back to them without
having to go through a hundred in one
podcasts and find the one question that
you want to get no now you can find it
in the book also it's got a new cover on
it which is black more cool and you know
because the QA is from you I kind of
need to thank everyone because this book
is not just lay for me anymore
now it's life in me and echo and
everyone that asked questions and help
with the podcast by asking questions so
thanks to you all for the new version of
our new book also the discipline equals
freedom Field Manual is now available
worldwide and if you've got questions
this book has answers if you're
wondering what workout should I do what
martial arts should I train in how do I
know what a good jiu-jitsu gym is what
should i eat what should I do when I'm
injured what should I do if I don't feel
like working out what should I do
something bad happens how should I
overcome failure if you've got those
kind of questions this book has the
answers discipline equals freedom Field
Manual get it for yourself and get it
for anyone else that might want answers
to these questions the book is not
normal it's not normal I know it's not
normal because you know why
I'm not normal no the book is it's black
and the book
it only has a black cover it has black
pages as well so some people don't like
that and you know what I say don't read
it yeah you don't if you don't want to
read that cool don't read it and as I
said if you want to get the book on
audio it is not on audible it is on mp3
as an album with tracks you can get it
through iTunes Amazon music and Google
Play that way you can listen to it as an
album with tracks this is a book that
you don't sit it's not a story mm-hmm
it's not a story you might want to
listen to one section of it at a
different time you might be saying hey I
need to listen to a section about
destroy your mode right how do I get
into destroyer mode one day you might
want to read about the fear of failure
or you listen to the fear of failure one
day you might need to hear sugar-coated
lies one day you might want to hear
about the warpath so you know when you
have it as an elm with tracks you can
listen to it in whatever order you want
you can set it as your alarm you can put
it in your playlist that kind of thing
which you can't do with a lame audible
book so that's that also if you like the
leadership principles that we talk about
on this podcast and you want to get them
for your team or business we have a
leadership and management consulting
company it's the premier leadership and
management consulting company did I say
that yes I did a chillon front me Lafe
JP Dave Burke if you want us to come and
work with your company and get your
leadership aligned and get your
leadership into destroyer mode email
info and echelon front comm and if you
have any more questions or answers for
us or something that you want to tell us
you can find us up on the interwebs on
Twitter on Instagram and on the Phase II
Paul
echo is at Echo Charles and I am at
Jocko willing and to the soldiers
sailors airmen and Marines who are
overseas right now defending our nation
and our freedom thank you for your
sacrifice and to the families of those
men and women thanks for supporting your
warriors while they are deployed that is
one of the hardest jobs in the world and
thank you for doing it and to the police
law enforcement firefighters paramedics
and other first responders thank you for
protecting us here at home you do not
get thanked enough I'm thanking you
right now and for the rest of you out
there maneuvering through life trying to
get the upper hand on the enemy or the
competitor or or trying to get the upper
hand and get control of yourself you
know what to do you know what action to
take you know how to win so get out
there and get after it and so until next
time this is echo and Jocko out